you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new Star
Wars Battlefront trailer just revealed
what we're gonna be blowing our money on
in November and yes it does have DLC
that will tie in with Episode seven so
important stuff first I know everyone
wants to know like how is this gonna tie
in with Episode seven when it's all
original trilogy stuff in here like we
see darth vader clearly he's gonna be
dead at Episode seven here's the deal so
the episode 7 dlc is gonna be the battle
of jakku that's the new planet that
we're gonna see an episode 7 the one
with the downed Star Destroyer here
connecting the dots you can surmise that
the Empire lost the battle star
destroyer crashed on the planet the game
itself is out November 17th that's when
you'll be able to play it if you
preorder the game you get access to the
DLC December 1st but everybody else will
get access to it December 8th so you'll
be able to play it no matter what and it
will be free content but you I mean
obviously you have to buy the game to
get it once we get through the trailer
I'll explain what's going on with EA and
games based on the new trilogy so we
start on Endor and like I said you know
most of these maps are taken from the
original trilogy for the most part the
games lifted from the original
battlefront game so you know if you
really like those you're really gonna
like this but EA married it to their new
game engine so it's an optimized
experience for like the new connected
streaming HD world of video games today
whenever the first battlefront games
came out YouTube was a brand new thing
nowadays the social experience of games
has gotten really meta so this just
takes advantage of that even though
we're on Endor I don't really know what
the presence of Ewoks is going to be I
imagine they'll be in there somewhere
there were a lot of things that they did
reveal it's still in a pre-alpha stage
all the actual gameplay that they showed
off at Star Wars Celebration is
pre-alpha stuff so we can't post that on
youtube yet this is all taken from a
PlayStation 4 but the actual character
models will be pretty close to this
we're in that age of gameplay when the
quality of cutscenes and actual gameplay
is getting closer and closer speeder
bike chase very familiar and here's the
big WTF Darth Vader popping his
lightsaber what's gonna happen is is
Darth Vader will be like an in-game
powerup available to players they didn't
they didn't really announce what the
specifics of that are only that he will
be available probably with some other
original trilogy characters too based on
which faction you're playing here we are
in another very familiar place this is
planet Hoth this excellent Canyon runs
obviously from Tatooine if anybody
remembers rebel assault they had like
the
artists Canyon run in that game I tied
so many times that was actually a das
game who remembers that
yay for nostalgia here's Boba Fett one
of the other power-ups in the game I
like the fact that there's a Jawa
sandcrawler in the background just like
putzing along like the no big deal these
scenes are taken from the imperial
shipyards on Sullust it's one of the
bigger new locations that they brought
into the game and yes this will be
available when the game is released it
won't be like DLC that you'll have to
get later yay for Millennium Falcon
another powerup in the game a lot of the
power-ups will probably also be based on
which map you're playing so like I said
you will still get that battle of jakku
dlc for free whenever the game's
released but if you want it a week early
you have to pre-order the game they
haven't announced all their special
editions too but typically they'll
release like a special edition with an
art book that's pretty standard
operating procedure for like the really
big games nowadays because it's EA
though you probably won't be able to buy
it in steam you'll probably have to buy
it through EA servers if you want to buy
digital download so now you're all
asking like what's going on with games
based on the new trilogy episode 7 8 & 9
because they're gonna be making cartoons
all kinds of stuff for this new trilogy
of course they're gonna be making video
games
Lucasfilm signed a 10-year deal with EA
to develop games based on its IP so all
the Star Wars games you see for the next
10 years will be e a games this Star
Wars Battlefront game is actually part
of the reason that they scrapped the
Star Wars 1313 project that bounty
hunter Boba Fett game that they were
making that everyone loves so much as
you can imagine
Disney Lucasfilm EA want to start off on
a really strong financial foot so
they're going with a franchise that they
know fans will buy a lot of the big
franchises chase trends so you don't see
them taking as many chances with small
indie games so for now most of the games
will be chasing like the really really
big titles like destiny Call of Duty you
can imagine I know everyone's hoping for
a new installment based on Jedi
characters that will come but it's
probably gonna take a little bit
typically games are released during the
Christmas shopping season all the Star
Wars movies are going to be released in
December so every time a new Star Wars
movie comes out expect a new really big
game so in related news there's a couple
more videos that I'm working on in the
in the next day or two there's a new
trailer for the flash that's pretty
crazy so I'm gonna add that to my flash
and arrow Q&A that'll be the next video
that I post and I'll talk about the
Batman vs Superman League I know
everyone wants to talk about that
trailer I can't post any
about it just because it's super illegal
like it's getting pulled down all over
the place then I'll be working on some
new daredevil so be sure to subscribe to
get all that stuff I'm gonna try and get
it all out before Game of Thrones on
Sunday so while you guys wait for all
that stuff to drop you can click here to
re-watch the Star Wars Episode 7 trailer
three or four more times and you can
click here for all my Marvel videos
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight